there's a lot you may not know about
Australian honker Chris Hemsworth before
he caught his big break as Thor Marvel's
got a thunder from scrapping with his
brothers - starring on an Australian
soap opera he is what we dug up about
the hammer wielding Avenger before he
took Hollywood by storm fashion forward
given his rugged Hollywood image it's
somewhat surprising that as a young kid
Hemsworth had a knack for well sewing
for some reason cross tissue enjoy he
told a w magazine I think it's because I
couldn't afford any cool clothes so I
was like I'm gonna make them myself
Hemsworth's interest in sewing faded
when he tried unsuccessfully to make his
own pants but the experience set him on
the path to his future career he went on
to explain I had a different idea every
week of what I wanted to do
professionally I'd see movies and be
inspired by things I guess that's why
acting fits because I get to pretend to
be all those things with no great amount
of risk or sibling rivalry Hemsworth has
fond memories of growing up with two
brothers even if their childhood antics
some like Fight Club than a hallmark
movie on the Graham Norton Show
Hemsworth brother Liam recalled the two
of them fighting when they were kids our
childhood rivalry was a bit vicious a
bit like The Hunger Games he wasn't
joking
apparently drawing a fight in their
kitchen Liam threw a knife for Chris's
head the handle side guy yeah it was
just like a warning like if you mess
with me I'll throw a soap star though
Chris and Liam found success in
Hollywood it was actually their oldest
brother Luke who found stardom first in
Australia after landing a role on the
soap opera neighbours in 2001 Luke
quickly grew disillusioned with acting
and started his own flooring business
where his younger brothers often worked
in 2004 Chris followed in Luke's
footsteps and landed a role on the
popular soap opera home and away which
led to heartthrob status Down Under
not to mention winning industry Awards
dancing Down Under while starring on
home and away Hemsworth competed on
Dancing with the Stars Australia in 2006
and lasted seven weeks
it's a tidbit from his past that he
doesn't normally bring up but during an
appearance on The Tonight Show Jay Leno
surprised him with a clip from his
dancing competition days
the audience applauded wildly but
Hemsworth assured them that ended my
dancing career
captain Kurt's dad in 2007 Hemsworth
left home and away and Australia to
pursue an acting career in Hollywood
before long he made his big screen debut
in the 2009 reboot of Star Trek playing
Captain Kirk's tombed father in an
intensely emotional opening scene
despite that fast break Hemsworth almost
quit acting and moved back to Australia
after Star Trek he was turning heads but
the roles weren't exactly pouring in I
was ready to pack it in and come on like
this is killing me work baguettes work
after a nine-month dry spell Hemsworth
landed a role in cabin in the woods a
horror movie produced by Joss Whedon the
Buffy the Vampire Slayer creates her who
would later go on to director Marvel's
The Avengers cabin didn't see the lights
of day until 2012 but it helped
Hemsworth make an important connection
it was Whedon along with cupboard in the
woods director Drew Goddard who
encouraged him to re-audition for the
title role in Thor after he had already
auditioned once and been rejected both
of them were looking at the trades at
the sort of top five guys for four and
saying why aren't you in the mix here
what happened I said I don't know I blew
my audition I guess after a supportive
phone call from Whedon to Thor director
Kenneth Branagh Hemsworth was back in
the mix and the rest was history though
do know this know what I know that at
what superhero strength after landing
the coveted role of the god of thunder
Hemsworth has started preparing for the
role and quickly realized he needed to
get bigger he told the Los Angeles Times
they kept saying yeah get as big as you
can as big as you can months later when
he returned for a final camera test he
put on his costume and went numb within
a couple minutes his costume was altered
but the director still told him to cut
back on a sickness Ken said you know
it's good you've got the size there and
there's just this one port back just a
little bit
itself our sisters are blocky hemsworth
i switched up his workout program to
include more cardio and less heavy
lifting though you wouldn't know it from
watching the movie it's in Cadillac a
red remake in 2012 a year after the
success of Thor Hemsworth appeared in a
remake of the 1980s classic Red Dawn
with a rotten tomato score of just 13%
the movie wasn't exactly a hit it also
seems like an odd follow-up film for
Hemsworth and that's because it really
wasn't during the dry spell after Star
Trek Hemsworth a London Red Dawn in the
same week he got the title role in Thor
and the like cupboard in the woods the
movie was actually shot before his
Marvel days regarding the delay in his
earlier films Hemsworth told MTV during
shooting I didn't have any clue there
would be problems and then afterwards I
heard there was a holdup and they were
having some delays and that now is kind
of a Benjamin Button thing as my films
come out I get younger and less
experienced thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]
[Applause]